good morning welcome to the program
today well labour says it will lay an
amendment to the queen's speech on
tuesday calling for a windfall tax on
oil and gas companies now that's always
been opposed by my first guest the
business secretary but the chancellor
has hinted that he may go down that
route there's also talk of tax cuts as
the government struggles with the cost
of living crisis quasi quatern joins us
now thank you good to see you and this
morning now i want to get on to the very
important business of the day first but
or later but firstly just to talk about
eurovision yeah we've come second what
is going on well we had a very good
contestant sam ryder did a good job
uh and uh he got lots of votes and it
feels right that ukraine won of course
well of course and i think the important
thing i i thought was when president
zielenski said uh that it should be
hosted as its customary in the in the
winning country and that will be ukraine
and i look forward to seeing it uh when
it's held there and they've talked about
um it being even a mario pole is that
something that the government uh in the
uk would try and support to try and make
sure that absolutely i mean uh president
zelenki was very clear that it will be
hosted in ukraine and he mentioned mario
paul and that's what we we hope to see
and obviously the country might need
support from others to
make that dream become a reality
absolutely i mean what we've done
uh is really support ukraine uh right
through from the beginning of this
crisis
and we'll continue to do so um now
ukraine say they've succeeded in pushing
russia out of the second city kharkiv
does our own intelligence support that
well i'm not here to uh talk about um
you know what the
war situation is
um i think it's been quite encouraging
what's happened and clearly uh president
putin's war aims initial war aims have
been completely frustrated um but we'll
just have to see how the situation
evolves do you think it's too far to go
to say that russia could be losing at
this point no i wouldn't i wouldn't make
any uh comments on that and i'm not in a
position to do so we've got an excellent
uh defense secretary you've got
excellent uh intelligence uh and uh
those
relevant uh cabinet ministers will have
a much clearer view than i do from just
reading what i i see and looking at uh
the the news reports it's clear to me
that russia's ambitions their initial
war aims as i've said have been
frustrated um but there's there could be
a long way to go and they may be forced
to refocus just on the donbass region in
the east of the country yeah they've
already done that i mean it was clear
that their initial
uh ambition their initial goal was to
take kiev uh that failed
uh and then they've scaled down uh their
their target their ambition
um and as far as i can see
they haven't got their secondary aim
either but but you know it's a it's a
it's an evolving situation and we just
heard uh just in the last few moments
from liz truss about the idea that
finland and potentially sweden could be
applying for nato membership is that
something that the uk would like to see
well i think um it's really up to
finland and sweden uh in terms of nato
membership that's something for them
they're sovereign countries
um and all of nato will have to take a
view
on on their application and what would
happen
well i mean you'd have to ask liz trust
i think she made her comments very
clearly um but we would have to just
rely on them we have to see what finland
and sweden want to do okay before we can
make a response okay um now the prime
minister's to visit belfast this week
now that's the first visit since the
assembly elections
what will his message be
i think his message is very much that uh
political stability the political
stability of northern ireland
is our number one priority as far as uh
northern ireland is concerned
and that we should be able to uh
act in a sovereign way northern ireland
is as much a part of the united kingdom
as uh england cornwall the south east
and we are responsible for that as a
government and i'm sure that'll be at
the core of his message
um
just to obviously um the dp have said
that they don't want to engage in power
sharing until parts of the northern
ireland protocol are fixed in their view
and various cabinet ministers including
liz trust including dominic rave on this
program have been very clear that they
don't think the protocol is currently
working does that mean that the uk
government is prepared to unilaterally
scrap parts of that protocol even
without eu agreement absolutely right i
mean throughout this whole debate even
before
uh the protocol and the treaty uh was uh
was
conceived we've had a number of people
in this country whose presumption has
been that the british government is
always wrong and that the eu is always
right and that's clearly too simplistic
we've tried to be uh enter into good
faith
we've tried to negotiate we've drawn the
treaty but we've always said even
article 16 of the protocol itself says
that it can be
abrogated unilaterally
if it's shown not to be working and
clearly
if political stability is our number one
priority and people are saying that they
won't go into power sharing if it isn't
changed we have to consider very you
know carefully how we can change it that
would break international law though
wouldn't it well i'm unclear as to this
because clearly article 16 is part of
the protocol itself and when you read i
did actually
take care to read it again just before
the program it says quite clearly that
there's a scope uh to change it
unilaterally unilaterally means that we
can do that ourselves without having to
reach agreement uh on the uh with the eu
and that's that's in the treaty the
article 16 is part of the protocol
whatever happens though there will be a
response from the eu if the uk did
decide to go down this route it could
mean a trade war and let's be clear
about what that means that means tariffs
that means things getting more expensive
for people in the middle of a cost of
living crisis well let's see what
happens i think we're getting ahead of
ourselves well that's what the eu have
said and also i mean any tariff uh
situation would have to be they have to
go through arbitrators it's not
something that they can just do
you know willy-nilly arbitrarily
immediately
they have to go through arbitrators and
you know let's let's uh rewind a bit we
got into a lot of problems because we
simply ruled out uh the ability to walk
away um article 16 is enshrined there's
a reason for it it does allow uh people
to act unilaterally and we've got
ultimately to be prepared to
to invoke it ultimately even if it could
mean things getting more expensive for
people in the uk so our number one
priority is political stability
of northern ireland now if many people
uh there uh nearly a majority are saying
that they cannot actually have a an
executive
uh without looking at the protocol again
we have to be prepared to do that we
need all we can even if even if it means
good it's getting more expensive in the
uk so the article 16 just
i mean that that is the logical
conclusion to what to what well i don't
accept the premises of your question i
don't think that they're necessarily
going to be able to slap tariffs uh
arbitrarily i think it'll take a very
long time
for that process to to work out
and as far as i'm concerned we have
absolutely the right uh to to invoke
article 16 and to re-open or re-examine
the protocol okay um the one thing that
i really uh i guess um i'm slightly
confused about it it's pretty clear that
yourself and others in government just
don't think the protocol
is working and that's because of the
checks between
northern ireland and and great britain
um but what i don't understand is it was
boris johnson who negotiated and signed
that protocol and when he did it was
pretty clear that this is a potential
consequence of what happened i just want
to play this is quite a long clip i'm
going to play but it's from an interview
i did with boss johnson in december 2019
so just before you know that it was
signed and i do think it is worth
listening to what he said
last month you told businesses in
northern ireland that they would face no
forms no checks no barriers of any kind
under your brexit
and you also went on to say that if
anyone asked them to fill out a form
they should phone you up personally and
you'll direct them to throw that form in
the bin well how come then that this
government document that was leaked uh
this week
says that that's not true that there
will be checks and forms are you telling
the truth yes i am and
look at what we say in our manifesto
look what we're going to deliver
the deal that we've done any checks no
absolutely not the deal we've done with
the eu is a brilliant deal and it allows
us to do all the things that brexit
was about so it's about taking back
control of our borders money laws but
unlike the previous arrangements it
allows the whole of the uk to come out
of the eu including northern ireland and
the only checks that there would be
would be if something was coming from gb
via northern ireland and was going on to
the republic then there might be checks
at the border into northern ireland
this document is talking about checks
both ways and that's wrong because there
won't be checks so you're saying that
this this is wrong the government's own
impact assessment is wrong your brexit
secretary is wrong all these people are
wrong and you are right yes because
because there's no question of there
being checks
on goods going uh nigb or gb ni so they
are because they're part of if you look
at what the deal is
we're part of the same customs territory
and
so pretty clear there absolutely no
checks and he said it numerous times
did he not understand the deal
was he lying to me no no he fully
understood the deal but of course like
in anything
uh you have to see what the actual
practice uh was when it happened nobody
else did though because the point i make
in that interview is that the
government's impact assessment the
brexit secretary the leaked documents
all of those were saying yeah there are
going to be checks he was on his own
saying there wouldn't be i think the
prime minister
i think the prime minister was right to
say
uh that we thought it would be a much
smoother uh process that's not what he
was saying he wasn't saying there would
be light touch checks he was saying
there would be absolutely no checks and
that was wrong wasn't it well what's
happened now is i think the eu have been
unreasonable frankly
and i was just reading a report that
they they won't use an i.t system uh
because uh it
breaks some of their sort of legalist
way of thinking they won't show much
flexibility and that's why we're in the
position uh we're in it's
the protocol isn't working and we have
to be prepared and it's an urgent
problem and we have to be prepared uh to
invoke our only 16 which we're in the
position we're in
because the deal that boris johnson
signed and negotiated it was inevitable
there was going to be checks on the rsc
so that's why i don't think it was
inevitable that uh the eu would be as
intransigent or as they have been
and it wasn't inevitable
that the people of northern ireland
would respond in the way they did to the
protocol because they've actually
experienced it and they're saying
majority the majority on the northern
ireland assembly do support the process
and they're there they are saying
the majority of uh
assembly members are from parties that
so so i'm not quite sure you're right i
mean the majority of people on the on
the assembly
are uh essentially on the unionist side
so they they broadly share uh what the
dup are things so the majority on the
assembly are from the union so so the so
you're right soon train has a the reason
why shin fein are the first minister is
because they got a plurality they got
they got more seats than anyone else but
they don't have a majority so so a lot
of the people actually uh and they've
said this uh but not everyone else has
unionists there's other there are
there's an alliance
and there's the alliance and then there
are the unionist uh parties which added
together are more than just sdlp that's
right that's right so but but it's clear
to me that without changes to the
protocol
you're not going to get um
an assembly you're not going to get an
executive okay and that's uh undermines
the fact you don't get an executive
undermines
actual stability
now labour are putting we need to uh
move on labour putting down an amendment
to the queen's speech this week calling
for a windfall tax on oil and gas
company profits
will this government support that of
course not i mean it's very unusual for
any government uh to support opposition
amendments to the queen's speech so
we're going to be opposing that i just
want to try and work out where you are
on the windfall uh tax on oil and gas
companies like this is what you told me
a couple of weeks ago you're very clear
i've never been a supporter of winfield
taxes
i have been
very clear on that publicly i think it
discourages investment so that's your
position yeah why i said that two weeks
ago two weeks ago exactly that's exactly
my position today just the reason i'm
asking is because this is what rashi
sunak said on windsville taxes this week
this is the chancellor he said
what i want to see is significant
investment back in the uk if that
doesn't happen then no option is off the
table yeah
it's who's right then
they're they're not contradictory
statements i've said personally that i'm
against them and he's the chancellor of
the exchequer he's responsible for the
budget he's responsible for tax policy
and he's saying
that no option is off the table and in
12 years in parliament i've i've always
heard chancellors they always say no
option is off the table it would be
foolish for any chancellor to say to
rule anything in or out four months
before the budget is due so it's
entirely reasonable you don't you don't
want to see a win i wouldn't want to see
it i've always argued against it
publicly and privately but as every
chance i can remember has said four
months before the budget no option is
off the table it's entirely reasonable
okay and now there are reports in the
sunday telegraph today that cabinet
ministers are criticizing the bank of
england for failing to control inflation
one reportedly saying it has one job to
do to keep inflation at around two
percent it's hard to remember the last
time it achieved its target do you share
their frustration so it is a matter of
fact that when the bank of england
became independent in 97 as you know
they had a monetary uh target inflation
target two percent that's true
and inflation's running in almost into
double digits now
so you know that that is an issue
clearly um but i think andrew bailey's
uh doing a good job in difficult times
uh these are completely unprecedented uh
times we've had uh the the uh kovid
pandemic we've had a huge uh spike in
economic activity after the the lockdown
restrictions uh were eased and then of
course you've got this war in europe for
the first time in 70 years with tanks
rolling into uh you know european
territory so all of these things mean
that it's a very difficult time and i
think he's doing a reasonable job but
it's true to say that that that two
percent is part of their their mandate
they have to keep it to two percent the
inflation and they failed on that well
it's been a very difficult uh time to do
that i think every country in the world
pretty much is having inflation running
uh in high single digits even double
digits okay and now i want to talk to
you a little bit about some comments
made by the prime minister this week
about working from home obviously many
more people
working from home as a result of the
pandemic and saying that it makes them
more uh productive that it helps them
with flexible working as well
particularly if you've got caring
responsibilities now this is what the
prime minister said about working from
home
he said my experience of working from
home is you spend an awful lot of time
making another cup of coffee and then
you know getting up
walking very slowly to the fridge
hacking off a small piece of cheese and
then walking very slowly back to your
laptop and then forgetting what it was
you're doing do you
share the prime minister's assessment
well look he's making a point very
vividly that you know people's
concentration his concentration our
concentration
isn't as focused perhaps at home than it
would be at work i think that's an
entirely reasonable i think that's an
entirely reasonable thing to say many
people uh say they might work much
better in a much more focused way in the
office do you agree though with what
he's saying well i i don't know about
the details of hacking off a small piece
of cheese or anything like that do you
think that's maybe a bit more of a
reflection about how boris johnson works
i think a lot of people work from home
in that way i mean we all have our
different ways of working from home um
but and i think but i think the point
he's making is that
i think majority actually would be more
effective
working in the office and the thing
about working in the office is not a
doctrinaire thing i think particularly
for young people if they're trying to
learn a profession or learn you know
about a business that face-to-face
contact is really important and i think
you know that's as business actually i'm
trying to encourage more people uh to go
back to the office and they can share
their experience uh with other
colleagues okay just got a couple of
things um just to finish off with
there's also been a focus on oxbridge
applications this week and whether in
the words of one cambridge professor
white private school educated boys are
the new disadvantaged candidates now
nadim zahar with the education secretary
said this week britain should be proud
of its private schools and the oxford in
cambridge shouldn't tilt the system to
accept more state school pupils
what's your position on this so i think
um nadi makes a good point i mean what
struck me about the private school
debate is that
from around the world people flock to
british private schools it's something
which brings money into the into the
country
it's something that renowned schools uh
all around the world and that's
something we should be proud of i don't
see any other country if they had those
kinds of institutions they'd be very
proud of having them at the same time
i wouldn't bash them it's not really
bashing them to say that actually it's a
good thing for more state school pupils
to be admitted in cambridge
statistics shows that state school
pupils actually outperform their private
school peers once they make it to these
universities your old school eaton at 48
offers i know that that was half on on
previous years but there's still an
awful lot of people from the top schools
going to oxford encampment look i think
it's a very competitive uh situation
where you have to go you know to top
schools not just oxford and cambridge
you know we we tend to obsess about
oxford cambridge we've got lots of
fantastic universities and we should
have wide access to them and i think
people should be able to to to go to
them from it whatever background they
they come from uh we are at a time and i
do know i have to let you go but very
quickly neil parish
the former concept of mp of course who
resigned after being caught watching
porn in the house of commons rumors he
might be standing in this by-election
i'd be very surprised if neil is
standing as an independent i mean he's
someone who's was very loyal to the
party he was an mep for many years he
was an mp for 12 years i'd be very
surprised if he did that okay thank you
very much for being on the program today
mr quan saying there quasi quantang